[music]
Wentworth Miller:
Could two buildings be more different in
concept and vision?
Wentworth Miller:
Whitman College, Princeton's
first modern, four-year
Wentworth Miller:
dormitory, is constructed in the
traditional Gothic style.
Wentworth Miller:
Meg Whitman, the former CEO of
eBay, the online auction
Wentworth Miller:
giant, gave $30 million to the
University for the $136
Wentworth Miller:
million project.
It was designed by Demetri
Porphyrios, who is
Wentworth Miller:
unapologetic for his traditional
approach to
Wentworth Miller:
architecture.
Demetri Porphyrios
I'm interested in doing Gothic
buildings which are robust,
meaning that they will have a
Demetri Porphyrios
longevity of life.
So the external wall has to be
properly constructed in stone,
Demetri Porphyrios
which is bonded with a brick
support behind it,
Demetri Porphyrios
et cetera, et cetera.
And it should be a wall
structure which will have to
Demetri Porphyrios
have at least a lifespan of
about 200, 250 years.
Wentworth Miller:
Far from traditional, the Lewis
Science Library, which
Wentworth Miller:
also houses the Princeton
Institute for Computational
Wentworth Miller:
Science, is unlike any building
you've never seen before.
Wentworth Miller:
New in its architectural forms,
new in it's methods of construction.
Wentworth Miller:
The project cost over $74 million.
Designed by the famous and
controversial architect, Frank
Wentworth Miller:
Gehry, the building was
primarily funded by a
Wentworth Miller:
$60 million gift from Peter Lewis,
the highly creative, former
Wentworth Miller:
CEO of Progressive Insurance.
Peter makes no bones about his
belief that Princeton also
Wentworth Miller:
needs architecture that
looks to the future.
Peter Lewis:
Frank, in my view, is the first great
architect of the 21st century,
probably more than the
Peter Lewis:
greatest architect of the 20th century.
Although he might be that as well.
Peter Lewis:
Whether history validates my view, remains to be seen.
No architect, no builder is
addressing the future any more
Peter Lewis:
than Frank is today.
Craig Webb:
I think we have afew kind of unwritten rules.
But one of them is if it just
looks anything like something
Craig Webb:
anybody has done, no.
And the second rule is, if it looks like
Craig Webb:
anything we've done, no.
Wentworth Miller:
Two builders, those two very
different visions.
[music]
Wentworth Miller:
Much of the story of Whitman
College is a story of stone.
Wentworth Miller:
Finding stone, cutting stone,
finding ways to support the
Wentworth Miller:
weight of stone, and finding
craftsmen who have the skills
Wentworth Miller:
to construct stone buildings
with techniques no longer in
Wentworth Miller:
general use.
[music]
John Zeigler:
The field stone, the bluestone, each piece was
handled, people estimate roughly
eight to nine times,
John Zeigler:
from the time it came out of the
quarry to the time it got
John Zeigler:
put through the original
guillotine, placed in a
John Zeigler:
pallet, shipped to the site.
And then picked up, chipped
away, piece by piece, by the
John Zeigler:
masons, up to 77 stone masons at
one point in time, with 30
John Zeigler:
laborers assisting them.
The limestone is saw-cut or
hand-chiseled to a particular
John Zeigler:
location on the building.
If you looked around the site,
you'll see many of those
John Zeigler:
pieces of limestone sitting on pallets.
They all have numbers on the
bottom of them, because they
John Zeigler:
all have a precise location on the building.
The field stone was about 5,000
tons, somewhere around
John Zeigler:
175,000 pieces individually
cut on site.
John Zeigler:
The limestone was approximately 2,500 tons,
somewhere around 38,000 to
40,000 pieces of limestone.
Wentworth Miller:
Much of Demetri's work was devoted to
the site plan and the creation
of courtyards.
Wentworth Miller:
One of the interesting
refinements, which he borrowed
Wentworth Miller:
from Ralph Adams Cram's Graduate
College, is that the
Wentworth Miller:
courtyards are not exactly
square, but just one or two
Wentworth Miller:
degrees off a right angle.
Most visitors probably aren't
conscious of this difference.
Wentworth Miller:
But it makes the experience of
the courtyards mysteriously
Wentworth Miller:
fascinating.
Meg Whitman:
You come up to the building and you just sort
of step back and say, wow.
[music]
Meg Whitman:
Interestingly, it may sound
simplistic, but I did it
Meg Whitman:
because it gave another 125 kids a year a
chance to go to Princeton.
Meg Whitman:
Beginning, middle and end of story,
because I am so fond of this place.
Meg Whitman:
I adored my time here.
And I want other people to have
that same opportunity.
Demetri Porphyrios:
We've taken up the challenge of how
you can actually work within
contemporary industrial
Demetri Porphyrios:
production and at the same time
give the sense of tactile
Demetri Porphyrios:
personality to a building.
So the materials that we
use are always what I
Demetri Porphyrios:
call natural materials.
Materials which are not going
through an industrial
Demetri Porphyrios:
production of manufacture.
That does not project the
coldness of industrial
Demetri Porphyrios:
production, but it actually
presents a more kind of humane
Demetri Porphyrios:
face, something that you can
actually touch, a building
Demetri Porphyrios:
that you will love to actually touch.
A building that you would love
to kind of lean against, to a
Demetri Porphyrios:
talk with a friend or whatever.
Meg Whitman:
You might have heard a funny story.
There was a summer executive
program here.
Meg Whitman:
And they were watching the
finishing touches being put on
Meg Whitman:
Whitman College this summer.
And one of the group said to one
of the faculty members at
Meg Whitman:
Princeton, "Boy, when Princeton
renovates a building, they
Meg Whitman:
really go to it."
They thought this had been
here for 100 years.
Wentworth Miller:
While the plans for Whitman College were
moving forward, the impossible occurred.
Wentworth Miller:
Princeton decided that Frank
Gehry, who had been rejected
Wentworth Miller:
in the past, could design a building for the
campus after all.
Peter Lewis:
Harold Shapiro was retiring as president.
And there was a dinner over at Forbes College.
Peter Lewis:
Harold takes me to the corner,
and he says, "We can get a
Peter Lewis:
Gehry building on campus."
I said, "Harold, there's no way."
Peter Lewis:
And he said, "Oh yes, we can."
And he said, "We have a need.
Peter Lewis:
We have to build the science library.
We have a wonderful site for it.
Peter Lewis:
The budget's $60 million.
Jerry, the provost and I,
got it all figured out.
Peter Lewis:
And we think it would be a great
spot to have a Gehry
Peter Lewis:
building on the campus."
I said something like, "Harold,
I don't think it's possible.
Peter Lewis:
But if you can get it done,
I'll pay for it."
[music]
Wentworth Miller:
Created with 88,000 pounds of stainless
steel from Sweden, 400 tons of
structural steel, 35,000
Wentworth Miller:
square feet of Canadian clay
brick, and almost 25,000
Wentworth Miller:
square feet of glass, the design
of Louis Library pushed
Wentworth Miller:
the limits of construction
complexity.
[music]
Frank Gehry:
Why these shapes?
Why do you twist and turn like that?
Frank Gehry:
Why would anybody do that?
It has to do with my belief
that a building can have
Frank Gehry:
feeling, that there can
buildings that are deadly
Frank Gehry:
inert and don't give you anything.
And I think my favorite buildings feel.
Wentworth Miller:
The Lewis Science Library represents an
attempt to rethink what a
library does in 21st century terms.
Shirley M. Tilghman:
The really intriguing, interesting ideas
in science increasingly are
happening at the boundaries
Shirley M. Tilghman:
between sciences, fields like
biophysics, fields like
Shirley M. Tilghman:
geochemistry.
These are fields that if you had
said those names 50 years
Shirley M. Tilghman:
ago, no one would have known
what you were talking about.
Shirley M. Tilghman:
The library is in fact sort
a representation of that.
Shirley M. Tilghman:
It is a way of our saying the
collective knowledge of the
Shirley M. Tilghman:
natural sciences is now brought
together in a single
Shirley M. Tilghman:
place on the Princeton campus.
Craig Webb:
The Tree House, which I don't know where that
name came from, but that was
originally the map room.
Craig Webb:
And I think it still contains
a lot of map cases.
Craig Webb:
And the way the roof planes
really hang out over the side
Craig Webb:
of the building and create
a kind of protective
Craig Webb:
environment.
Because it has these roofs that
are cantilevered off the
Craig Webb:
side of the building, kind of
shade the ground around them.
Craig Webb:
And then really connect the
building to the trees, which I
Craig Webb:
guess is where tree house idea came from.
I love the atrium that comes
through here and the
Craig Webb:
exploration of color, which is
related to painting and to
Craig Webb:
perception of the world around us.
In particular on this building, I
Craig Webb:
was looking at Kandinsky.
His paintings have lots and
lots of different colors.
Craig Webb:
And the part that's the most
interesting to me is the way
Craig Webb:
the colors relate to each other.
And then the most exciting part
is then you finally paint
Craig Webb:
the building.
And a lot of really unexpected
things start to happen.
Craig Webb:
Because now you're dealing
in full scale.
Craig Webb:
There's a lot of daylight that
comes into this building.
Craig Webb:
And the colors start to bounce,
one off the other.
Craig Webb:
It produces a whole different
palette of colors that you
Craig Webb:
weren't quite expecting.
[music]
Wentworth Miller:
Two very different buildings, two
extreme visions.
Wentworth Miller:
In very different ways, they
embody an ideal of excellence,
Wentworth Miller:
of doing things better than you did before.
And in very different ways,
they both encapsulate the
Wentworth Miller:
deep-rooted ideals of Princeton
University as a
Wentworth Miller:
university.
They embody both the venerable
traditions that provide links
Wentworth Miller:
with its past and the creativity
and innovation with
Wentworth Miller:
which it will lead us into the future.
[music]